so you're doing stand-up yeah where you
doing stand-up comedy cellar huh and
then la I do the akame store you ever do
like cruise ships and I did one cruise
ship and I'll never do it again a friend
said don't do it you'll hate it and I
got there's like it's gonna be great a
paid vacation and then I was bombing and
shout his three shows why did he do a
bombing case with people on the cruise
don't get you mostly wheelchairs and I'm
using this like younger material so I
became famous for being bad everyone was
like hey let's go see this guy he's
horrible yes it is free so everyone goes
to the show right and then I went to the
pool one day and I put on this a
disguise so so humiliated like I'm Oh
Jay yeah and his one lady came to what
kind of disguised he approaches like hat
glasses and no one's recognizing you I I
was just not looking at anyone cuz I
just want to go to the pool I was stuck
in my room cuz you were the bad comic on
the courage of the terrible Oh God would
you say bomb like no one laughs there
was probably a couple but it's like 45
minutes um too much silence this after
one show this lady came out to me she
was kind of standing around cuz I also I
had to say goodbye to people after you
bomb you gotta beg thank you for coming
oh and this one ladies hanging around I
was like oh maybe this is like a fan or
something and she goes I just have to
tell you you look exactly like my dead
son died a month ago and they didn't
they couldn't get refund on the tickets
and then I was like I'm so sorry and
then I kept running into her because
we're on a boat cuz you can't even
escape the people on the boat or the
beautiful bombing in front yes and then
she I go into this bar and she's there
and she said come over and her whole
family's like oh my god and he sounds
like him and then she wanted to go rock
climbing with me and I can't say no so
now I'm doing activities you can't say
no cause you feel like hey I look like
her dead son and she's getting to relive
those moments yeah and you felt bad for
her yeah you're a good guy so you did
all these activities yes and then I
could tell like I wasn't acting like her
son it was kind of pissing her off like
I was scared to rock climb more than
like seven feet up and she's like just
go I could feel I wasn't dude what a
great movie that would be you you're a
young comic you're bombing on a cruise
ship you need a woman who think she's
like your son and then she starts taking
activities before you know what you're
living with her
yes you know what I mean with maids
because I'm sure she'd take you in yeah
and it something happens
yeah I'm figured that part out will
write it later yeah